good friend from the NFL Media Group
joining us here are the day after Jared
golf gets paid he is Maurice jones-drew
how are you mjd how are you I'm doing
great
Rams had to do this clearly and what do
you think of this deal for Jared Goff
well I gotta tell you a quick story
there was one point in my career where I
was kind of uh I was a little down and I
was banged up and had to get rehab and I
rehab University of California and there
was a freshman quarterback there who was
going through a similar situation and it
was Jared golf and I got a chance to get
to know him really well do that all
season he was rehabbing his shoulder and
I was rehabbing in my knee and ankle and
so uh you know it when you meet someone
at that age and you kind of get a chance
to talk to him a little bit they see him
grow throughout his career I think it's
amazing that they got this deal done and
the way they got it done right where it
wasn't all in the media no one even knew
was going to happen we had kind of
hinted and talked to him about it a
little bit but he did a great job of
saying but when the time has come the
time will come and they got it done
right before the season and so you know
the Rams do a great job of handling
their business paying their guys that
produce form Jared's done a great job
since you know growing each year I was
the under coach Nick Bay getting better
and better and better going to Chicago
last year and and the Rams paid him for
that and so uh it well deserved I think
you saw the love from the RAM Lee all
the players realized you know Instagram
and pictures and tweeting stuff out and
saying how how much he deserves and he
does but he does a great job form and so
it's exciting it's an exciting time
right now to be a part of the Rams
organization amen I'll tell you this mjd
cuz you hit on it I said it at the top
of the show if you think you've got the
right guy and the coach that you you've
got is the right guy and the general
manager that you got is the right guy
and every word is an agreement that this
is the guy then you pay the guy and you
pay the guy what the market value is if
it's the tops then that's fine because
it will be topped eventually and you
don't want to pay above that because
you've waited it you know it does seem
that
simple but is it really though well you
know Kevin dim often in their in their
front office with officers less to eat
and everyone they do a great job of
identifying players that they that they
feel will be part their their nucleus
for a long time and if you play well
they reward you I think that's how it
goes about I know Aaron Donnell
situation was a little tough and they
were working on that one for a while but
they found a way to get that done and
from there it's kind of been you know
Todd was next I'll see Jared they
identify brain and cookies a guy they
wanted and so they've done a great job
of identifying talent and and and really
you know gone you know outside the box
thinking outside the box to get these
guys to be locked in for a long period
of time you know I I just think back
every now and then when something
significant involving involving the rams
happens mjd and and i think back to that
thursday night game in seattle on the
15th of december back in 2016 golf's
first year on the job
jeff fishers fired just days before
right bones fossil the special teams
coach is the interim guy they get
destroyed up in seattle you're across
the aisle for me as i'm flying back with
my good friend Kara henderson and you're
the radio guy and it was a morgue on
that flight I mean there wasn't a single
sense that this organization would be
copycatted or wanted to be copycatted or
had a a quarterback worthy of a hundred
and ten million dollars of guaranteed
money on that night you know and that
and that great things were about to
girly was complaining about the high
school offense it really is amazing how
far this team has come in just a short
amount of time
MJ d.o rich I remember like it was
yesterday it was a I was rock bottom I
feel like the Rams organization that
that play back that was kind of the
lowest of the low
and those guys did a really good job of
banning together that offseason and
working out and then obviously you hire
Sean McVeigh and he gets his staff in
there and he goes out and gets some
critical pieces like Andrew Whitworth
and you know Robert Wood and guys that
can come in and then you bring in Wade
Phillips and all of a sudden when you
start adding the right ingredients to
this this uh this disorganization things
can turn quickly they hit on the draft
last couple drafts I mean they started
they really started putting pieces
together and so you know I figured that
Jarrod would get paid I didn't know it
was gonna be this close to be honest
what the items will be this soon but I
knew it was coming because think of all
these beating every quarterback except
for two that I can really think of
Carson Wentz
I'll see what the Eagles that he lost to
them but then him and Tom Brady those
are the only two that I could think of
right now that he hasn't beaten and so
when you talk about a quarterback that
is you know throwing 30-plus touchdowns
a year and you guys are every year with
the new coach he's gotten better the
team has gotten better you know it's it
you have to try to reward that and then
the one thing that I love about the Rams
they're not afraid to set the bucket
they're not afraid to say like you said
they're not afraid to get the deal done
early and shut the market because in a
couple of years that deals is going to
be a benchmark and it's gonna end up
going further obviously we you know
we'll talk about the Zeke deal but they
said Todd the market a couple years ago
with Todd Gurley deal well then now
everyone's gonna come up and try to pass
it and you're gonna look in a couple
years now it'll be like man you got Todd
Gurley for that that's crazy
and the same thing with Jared golfers as
back press that comes along and other
quarterbacks come along that deals gonna
look even he knows like man you got
Jerry golf for that and so the Rams do a
great job of going out there and making
sure that they they get both the you
know the players happy and the
organization and before we get to Zeke
give me a good story about what why you
think Golf is the future that many fans
who see this contract for golf and think
that he's not worthy of it because maybe
his outward demeanour or the the
inability to it
or not inability or or let's just put it
this way on his resume there isn't that
signature postseason win that you could
say it was on his back I mean that
Monday nighter obviously were everywhere
everything went on tilt against the
Chiefs he was dynamite and he's been
that way in many regular-season games
give me a good story as to what golf
does that you know that others might not
okay this has nothing to do with the
league but you know rich I'm uh I'm one
of the toughest individuals you've
probably met a day you know you're in
your life and so we're at Cal one day
and I'm having a few hours at my house
by myself I don't have anything to wear
so I wore all my UCLA stuff to go train
there and as I was training Jarrett kind
of walked up to me and he was like hey
man like I need you to take off all your
silly stuff this is our building you
need to respect us at that time I was I
think I was like 26 27 so I was right in
the middle of my career and all those
guys talking to me like this you know
but he pulled me to a sign he had he
gave me some cow stuff to where he was
kind of like look you know I get it
you know it's all good let's compromise
- compromise and that's leadership at a
very young age he showed tremendous
leadership now you may not see it all
the time but when you're on the field
and you watching it when things go bad
there's you never see him crack you
never see him complain you never see
until his hands up
he's even killed and he's a great leader
and those attributes in that story I'm
telling you it's hard for at 18 nine
year old person to come up to an NFL
player or an older person and and it's
you know kind of show that great
leadership like I know if I was 18 or 19
I probably said something completely
different but he came in there he
reasoned with me he talked with me we
had an understanding and we went on
about our day and that's what you get
from Jared golf all the time he comes in
right away he you know he's always in
the building learning he's right under
coach McVeigh all the times they can be
on the same page but when you look at
the playoff games there was no panic
when they played the same that second
half of the same
game Jerrod through some really good
passes finding guys getting open guys
are making plays for but it's because of
that confidence in that leadership that
he has where he doesn't he doesn't panic
he doesn't get you know we see a lot of
quarterbacks get frustrated they get hit
a ton you don't see that with it and so
it's not necessarily one players just
his mindset his attitude that he brings
every day is why this pain is you know
you're been so successful now I know
there's a lot of people that say all
they're not going to win they're not
gonna go to the playoffs this year blah
blah blah blah blah I have to I have to
disagree and say all they've done is
gotten better
you have you added more pieces to the
puzzle defensively draw free agency in
the draft offensively refix and
rebuilding an offensive line getting
ready so you have a dash for next year I
know some people say you have to
redshirt guys that are coming in for the
top of line how can they how can they
get better I mean we just have to wait
and see but I think the leadership good
Jared shows and the way that these
players gravitate around them and then
the big time throws that he's made in
the regular season to summon the
postseason when need be um it shows that
they're ready to go I mean go to New
Orleans three times last year lose the
first two and find a way to eke out the
third and I get it everybody's going to
say talk about the you know the penalty
but let's remember Drew Brees had an
opportunity to win the game after that
didn't do it and Jared finally found a
way to get a couple of yards in the
field goal range and make it happen and
so he's done he's done more than enough
to deserve this type of pavement and
then get the respect that his owner had
that he's earned and so we'll have to
wait to see this year but I think the
Rams are ready to go
he turns 25 on October 14th and he's
signed through 2024 the Rams are set
with golf and Gurley for quite some time
and that's the way you win football
games if you if you bet on the right
people Maurice jones-drew here on the
Rich Eisen show alright our colleague at
the NFL Media Group Jane Slater just
said that Zeke is expected to get twenty
to twenty five reps week one what are
your thoughts on that subject
yeah he's ready to go I mean first of
all you know I know this this contract
was gonna be a little let me say this
kudos to Jerry Jones and the Cowboys
because I didn't know they had to pay
everybody right you pay Damon Smith if
you play Lyle Collins you have DAC steel
I didn't know about the first two guys
that's all we talked about was DAC and
seekin Amari Cooper so we never thought
about all the other players that they
have to pay so kudos to the Cowboys for
trying to find a way to get everyone in
this building and locked in um I think
that you know Zeke is ready to go
I know Marshall foot went down there
train with him and I know Marshall you
know hanging around Marshall he doesn't
play any game so he probably has him in
the best shape of his life but I think
Zeke has been there before and when I
held out in 2012 I came back and end up
getting 23 24 carries that game it
wasn't that big of a deal he's got to
make sure that you're hydrated and you
know that you get IVs at halftime and
all those different things so that you
don't cramp up but I I firmly believe
that Zeke will be ready to go week one
and the Cowboys to be back in that and
Metta NFC the NFC East race yeah so what
advice would you give to Melvin Gordon
right now oh if I'm Melvin Gordon I'm AM
I'm not sure what up I'm not gonna lie
to you I think that this is gone you
know there's been a history with the
charges for a long time and you know
talking with a lot of people sometimes
teams have to see the valuing you that
they don't normally see because again
you know they're in their building they
see every day
and they may think hey well you're not
this you're not bad but there is a value
where we're movin Gordon should be and I
firmly believe is and I've said there's
multiple times without Melvin Gordon I
don't know if this team can what go you
know ten games and like they do have
twelve and four lash I think they
they're gonna lose a couple and and
remember the Chargers notoriously don't
start fast so
not having Melvin Gordon and and having
somebody's other back that you want to
use like off the necklace was more like
a third down situation ingesting Jones
who was kind of year he he can be a bell
cow guy he just lost a lot of depth
because of Melvin Gordon so I think is
still a rivers gets older you want to
always have pieces and players around
them and you need a guy that's gonna
demand an eight-man box well I don't
think Austin Apple is going to demand a
eight-man box and I think it's gonna be
a little rough on these guys early on
and hopefully they could figure it out
but they'll see quickly how important
Melvin Gordon is to this team into that
office well I mean they went for know
without him closing down the stretch
last year that's that's the issue that
is so if you're Tom telesco you you're
probably thinking that and then what do
you make of Albert Brewers report on if
you heard this but the Eagles were the
team that raised their hand and said
we'll trade for Melvin Gordon and we'll
flip you Jordan Howard in a mid-level
pick and the Chargers according to
Albert said no to that what do you think
of that problem where you get like when
teams say hey go go seek out a trade and
you go do it which I was a part of and
then you get these great reports back
are these great offers back the team
says no no but sudden is like what do
you want me to do so you're gonna hold
me hostage and not allow me to to go
somewhere and be happy I have to play
for you right I have to honor the
contract when we see teams every year
not honor the contract and so that's
where it starts to get personal and I
think that's what you don't want in
these negotiations I remember speaking
with the Rams about the Aaron donald
situation when he was holding out a
couple years ago and the biggest thing
that one when I spoke with some of the
brass that I said look as long as
there's constant communication and it's
not personal and it doesn't you don't
ever want the player to come back and be
upset you don't ever want the player to
come back and be in the locker room to
kind of be a cancer in the lock you
don't want that and the only way you can
do that is by having constant
communication and and being and just
being not fair but just being honest
with each other you say look we're not
going to pay you that's fine he's you go
out and find a trait that we're happy
with
this is what we're looking for I think
the Chiefs did that with D Ford uh I
want to say during the combine I had
heard when the Chiefs for like hey look
this is what we're looking for for d4 to
go find a trade partner and we'll trade
them and they did and there was no
ill-will from there now when you talk
about the four games that's a small
sample size we're talking about possibly
all 10 games with milk
now some people this is like a backup
quarterback sometimes like sometimes
when you have a backup quarterback you
get still a game or two maybe three in
the Eagles case you can go to the Super
Bowl right and that may happen in a
small sample size but throughout the
course of a season I had a Melvin Gordon
it's going to end up weighing on you
very quickly here and so I just think
that you know and I'm a firm believer
this rich I firmly believe that good
morning uh not good morning football
game day morning is great when all your
guys are there right when you are heard
Lutz throw me in there every now and
then sprinkle me in there a little bit
we're we're phenomenal when I'm gone
that's okay I'm not supposed to be there
all the time but I think if you were
gone it wouldn't be the same show I
think if Kurt was gone it wouldn't be
the same show right so that that's kind
of how it goes and so it's a same thing
in the NFL you need your best players on
the field to win games this league you
can't win games with backups like you
did the whole adding body subtracting
does not work and so we'll see how it
goes but I just look at that this guy
granted it was different when Andrew
buckles on the Colts but still I think
they have a tough day up a tough stretch
they they don't have to try to find a
way to to eke out some games here I'm a
man and I have left
give me your Super Bowl prediction what
do you got for me Maurice jones-drew
well I said this yesterday on Power
Rankings but since Miami is my favorite
city so it's an amazing place I want my
two favorite teams to go so I'm with
those Jax Rams remove you remove the
heart from it seriously like you don't
don't use Rams go back okay you do think
the Rams go back okay I do I do believe
the Rams go back and I think it's going
to be in the AFC as out of two teams I
think it
because they'll be Rams Patriots again
to be honest with you you know what
that's not a that you're not far off I
wanted to say Chiefs yesterday too but
it's just you know with T b12 and
Belichick and you did you usually
they'll figure something out you know I
don't even know what their defense is
going to look like and it's going to be
better well right that's the whole thing
though is that at some point everyone
realizes just really do your job and and
everything will be fine and that's that
that usually it just depends on will
they lose too many games in the first
eight to prevent them from getting on a
plane or prevent them from having a home
game last year they went on the road
anyway and they beat the Chiefs so you
never know mjd right thanks they call
brother we'll see you soon enjoy your
trip to Carolina copywriter you got a
man that's Maurice jones-drew in the
Honda insider report for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app